le bus santé pour femmes a effectué son
premier passage dans le département à
rambouillet issu d'un partenariat entre
les hauts de seine et les yvelines il
propose en accès à des services de
dépistage et de conseil entièrement
gratuit l'objectif c'est vraiment de
pouvoir toucher des femmes qui ne vont
pas se présenter spontanément vers les
dispositifs existants et là on est dans
un environnement anonyme confidentiel ne
connaissent pas les professionnels qui
se trouve dans le bus et elles vont
davantage s'est penchée une première
partie santé met à disposition un chargé
de prévention un médecin et une
psychologue
les femmes peuvent tester leur vue leurs
auditions vérifier leur taux de diabète
et de cholestérol et surtout se confier
si l on ressente le besoin
l'idée c'est de l'art propose un
dépistage auditif visuel mais derrière
tout ça on est aussi la peau essayer de
d'échanger avec sow la prévention santé
de façon générale c'est bien parce que
il ya des personnes qui ne se font pas
consulté et qui pourraient peuvent
bénéficier à voir les solutions à propre
et à leurs problèmes pas de consultation
mais bien de la prévention l'objectif
est ensuite de les diriger vers les
professionnels du secteur géographique
plus que leur santé un autre volet
conseils et écoute de vie leur est
proposé avec un officier de prévention
ou en avocat mais ça me semble important
actuellement d'informer les femmes de
qu'elles connaissent leurs droits quelle
qu'elles puissent poser des mots sur des
situations qu'elles vivent chaque jour
et qu'on puisse les aider à cheminer et
éventuellement à judiciariser une
situation si si l'infraction est commise
quelles en sont victimes et psychologues
et j'ai vu aussi l'aide sociale aussi
donc ça m'a aidé et m'a donné des
informations des adresses la roma c'est
très important pour moi
ce premier but en france rempli ses
objectifs d'information et de rupture de
l'isolément des femmes il sillonne les
deux départements lors de ses premiers
arrêts une cinquantaine de femmes a pu
le visiter chaque jour